u.s troops in iraq will be at the top of
the agenda
during prime minister mustafa al-qaeda's
meeting with the u.s president in
washington
their first meeting comes at a critical
time
the recently appointed prime minister
says iraqis still
need u.s assistance to counter the
threat from isil
but they don't need direct military
support on the ground
right now we see iraqi defense
capabilities have improved maybe we need
help and american presence and training
and intelligence with regard to weapons
but the situation
doesn't require a wide military response
more than 5 000 u.s soldiers are
stationed in iraq
some iraqi mps want fewer kadumi took
over in may
when baghdad's relations with washington
were seen by some
as being especially precarious the
american drone strike killing of iranian
general rasim solemani
an iraqi militia leader abu mehti
al-mohandas in baghdad in january
prompted shia mps to demand u.s forces
leave iraq
after months of anti-government protests
kadumi inherited many problems
three months in and his administration
has also faced challenges
such as protests by pensioners which
hindered plans to cut state salaries
as oil revenues dropped drastically
covet 19 infections continue to reach
record highs
and militia groups taunt the government
with regular rocket attacks
targeting iraqi bases and the heavily
fortified green zone
home to the u.s embassy i call it the
make or break visit
now that he is about 100 days in office
we need to see how strong he is
many people doubt if he is strong enough
to actually
do everything he promises he promised
the country
the form ahead of iraq's intelligence
has often had to deal with the rivalry
between the united states and iran
his first official visit was to tehran
last month
before flying to washington kadumi was
asked whether or not he was carrying any
messages from tehran
he replied we do not play the role of
postman in iraq
while the white house meeting is about a
plan to reconfiguratize between baghdad
and washington
its outcome will have consequences
beyond iraq's borders
dorsi jabari al jazeera baghdad